I'd seen some crazy pointing that and
from the girl's point of view yeah girl
dominates the guy oh yeah I've seen
where like girls are wearing a strap-on
and I'm like [ __ ] the guy alright
you're gonna I have not been looking
hard enough
I suppose hard enough I've been looking
hard enough for the heart I shoot you're
gonna have to send me a link to gladly
[ __ ] watch it right now who cares you
don't like this alright sure sure it'd
be great if it was like one of like the
first things open in your in your
bookmarks I got porn on my bookmark nah
pornhub I think it's pornhub.com pornhub
calm that's my favorite porn site by the
way it's that different than YouTube you
born you porn yeah they're all kind of
the same way just think they got under
videos hug tube - babe - what's the one
that would have like four days yes one
xvideos calm okay
let's see here strap-on I don't know
what type of [ __ ] guy it just sounds
like somebody talking strap-on [ __ ]
guy let's see let's see what's this one
is this so a woman having sex with a man
yeah here we go here we go yeah let's do
this let's do this this is a woman
[ __ ] a guy in the ass with it and
she's never seen porn like yes never
know I apologize to all potential
employers by the way I come across this
video of me sing the most all right so
you're smoking a cigarette he's about to
lick the tip of the dildo he's look like
maybe it hasn't been in any I mean it's
a new dildo you know you know yeah
that's true
hmm wow that's really in his mouth it
doesn't really look like a penis
she's pretty hot get to the [ __ ] set
this is what oh wow
there we go ah what do you think of that
the guy's not hard I know but I noticed
about a lot of poor my guys are getting
you [ __ ] in the acids and not to be
hard yeah
how do you feel it's I don't know it's
not he he just mostly looks like he's in
pain he doesn't look too happy about it
I think he's enjoying it how do you know
I don't know [ __ ] more guys than you
yeah that's true that's pretty hot
actually my jerk off to this later yeah
we're some crazy ass [ __ ]
there we go I like you in the woman
dirty talk really turns me on
she smacked him and then a second later
we heard the sound of Russia
I mean you guys can't see this mute but
the you know they'll talk and then the
the sound will come later
oh do this much fat one oh look at you
you're appreciating fat oh sorry obese
ovenbirds let's see obese men bows oh
here we go
fat girls see a crazy ass fat girl
[ __ ] okay this woman's huge alright
she's huge man I'm telling you see if I
get into this every part of her body is
making a jiggle
[Applause]
[Music]
she's supposed to be bouncing on it
which it seems too heavy to be oh shoot
I was gonna point out something and then
you stop [ __ ] on I've seen I got
another corner before his penis goes to
the left it's like one of the sleepy
woods hmm ah he's really hard for it
he likes fat girls oh he's a
professional that one oh wow
yeah I don't think I'm gonna [ __ ] a fat
girl change my mind I respect fat woman
and I if you're obese bimbo go for it
but Syd I just I'm not attracted to them
that's what I have learned from today I
have I have learned a great life lesson
yes yeah that's some crazy porn out
there like people [ __ ] on each other
and yeah in Germany right they have some
on this website we're not watching that
no watch okay no I don't want to see
that I really doubt there's some porn
that I just don't want to see sure sure
all right well yeah that's probably good
much comment below and tell me if you
have sex with a fat girl
[Music]
[Laughter]